you cannot go to your first day of
school like that you're in the red
states now I've got to prepare you for
this world be a lamb and make your mouth
another drink you know son the nail that
sticks out gets hammered down I am being
terrorized out there all day every day
aren't you being overly dramatic
normally I would take that as a
compliment I think a mix does startle
you I certainly did not mean to make
that sound
that's supposed to feel it's supposed to
be a man and do
your situation at school might get a
whole lot better just turn down low
why did you stop wearing blue Jane I'm
compromising myself at reasons I don't
even understand I mean you're not
getting beaned in the head as much
anymore
what am I going to do with you I am
announcing my candidacy for homecoming
queen
how do you want to be identified gay
straight transgender gender
obliviate err free well I was gonna
reclaim it as my own anyway
are you serious you do what you want but
from now on you're on your own
this is a simple case of decency versus
depravity
if life keeps you you you can call me a
freak okay you're all freaks food is
that what being a teenager is all about
and now ladies and gentlemen here comes
Billy blue
was the f4 it's for free you freak
you
you